I'm on the Energy and Commerce Committee.
I love how the media all of a sudden thinks that AI is a topic that we should be talking
about.
I've been talking about this in Washington, D.C. since I came to Congress.
The committee I serve on got the jurisdiction over AI.
We have a bipartisan work product, a marker bill, that was put out after hundreds and
hundreds of hours of work by my friend Jay Obernolte of California working directly with
Congresswoman Lori Trahan of Massachusetts because we need a federal framework for AI.
And it is something that Congress needs to do.
It's got to be a lawmaking exercise.
Our problem is Washington and the lawmaking process doesn't move as fast as the technology.
And that's what you've seen with social media, and it's run amok.
There need to be guardrails in place.
What we cannot have is 50 states all doing it their own way.
We will over-regulate ourselves to the point where we will become Europe and the innovation
will not be here in the United States of America.
I mean, one cryptic tweet and all of a sudden everyone's hair is on fire about AI.
I work on AI in AI policy every day, but it's not something that the mainstream picks up.